so we are given this function h of x and
we're asked over which interval does h
have a positive average rate of change
so like always pause this video and have
a go at it before we we do this together
all right now let's work through this
together and to start let's just remind
ourselves what an average rate of change
even is you can view it as the change in
your value of the function
for a given change in the underlying
variable for given change in x we could
also view this as
if we want to figure out the interval we
could say our x final minus our x
initial and in the numerator it would be
the value of our function at the
x final minus the value of the function
at our x initial now they aren't asking
us to calculate this for all of these
different intervals they're just asking
us whether it is positive
and if you look over here as long as our
x final is greater than x initial in
order to have a positive average rate of
change we just need to figure out
whether
h at x final
is greater than h at x
initial
if the value of the function at the
higher end point is larger than the
value of the function at the lower end
point then we have a positive average
rate of change
so let's see if that's happening for any
of these choices
so let's see h of
0
this endpoint is going to be equal to
0.
if i just say one eight times zero minus
zero and h of two is equal to one eighth
times two to the third power is
eight so one-eighth times eight is one
minus four so that's going to be
this is negative three and so
we don't have a situation where
h at our end point at our higher end
point is actually larger this is a
negative average rate of change so i'll
rule this one out and actually just to
help us visualize this i did go to
desmos and graph this function and we
can visually see that we have a negative
average rate of change from x equals 0
to x equals 2. at x equals 0 this is
where our function is at x equals 2 this
is where our function is and so you can
see
at x equals 2 our function has a lower
value you could also think of the
average rate of change as the slope of
the line that connects the two endpoints
on the function and so you can see it
has a negative slope so we have a
negative average rate of change between
those two points now what about between
these two so h of 0 we already
calculated a 0 and what is h of 8
well let's see that's 1 8 times 8 to the
third power
well if i if i do 8 to the third power
but then divide by 8 that's the same
thing as 8 to the second power so that's
going to be 64 minus 8 to the second
power minus 64. so that's equal to 0. so
here we have a 0 average rate of change
because this numerator is going to be 0
so we can rule that out and you see it
right over here when x is equal to 0 our
function's there when x is equal to 8
our function is there and you can see
that the slope of the line that connects
those two points is zero so you have
zero average rate of change between
those two points
now what about choice c so let's see h
of six
is going to be equal to
1 8 times 6 to the third power so let's
see 36 times 6 is 180
plus 36 so that is going to be 2 16
2 16 minus 36
216 is 6 times 6 times 6 and then if we
divide that by 8 that is going to be the
same thing as this is 36 and then we
have 6 8 of 36 so this is going to be
this is going to simplify to 3 4
times 36 minus 36 which is going to be
equal to negative 9. you could have done
it with a calculator or done some long
division but hopefully what i just did
makes some sense it's a little bit of
arithmetic and so at h of 6 we have our
function is negative 9 and then h of 8.
i'll draw a line here so we don't make
it too messy h of 8 we already know is
equal to 0. so our function at this
endpoint is higher than the value of our
function at this endpoint so we do have
a positive average rate of change so i
would pick that choice right over there
and you could see it visually h of 6
when x is equal to six
our value of our function is negative
nine and when x is equal to eight our
value of our function is zero and so
the line that connects those two points
definitely has a positive slope so we
have a positive average rate of change
over that interval
now if we were just doing this on our
own we'd be done but we could just check
this one right over here if we compare h
of 0 we already know is 0 and h of 6 we
already know is equal to negative 9. so
this is a negative average rate of
change because at the higher end point
right over here we have a lower value of
our function so we'd rule this out and
you see it right over here if you go
from
x equals 0 where the function is to x
equals 6 where the function is it looks
something
it looks something
like that clearly that line has a
negative slope so we have a negative
average rate of change